netflix employees walk out to protest
dave chappelle's special and the media
gush over them plus the biden
administration says they've got vaccines
for five-year-olds but the kids will
still have to mask i'm bench bro this is
the bench bureau show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
stand up for your digital rights take
action at expressvpn.com slash ben we'll
get to all the news in just one moment
first you may have noticed that uh
inflation has set in and that means that
you might have some extra bucks in your
pocket and you're thinking where do i
invest this i can't invest in bonds
because they're going to pay me back in
inflated dollars and if i invest in
stocks i'm not sure where the stock
market is going considering all of the
uncertainty well there's one place that
very wealthy people tend to invest that
very few other people do and that of
course is in art you don't need to be a
hedge fund guru to know that to become
rich you should invest like the rich
people but investments like luxury real
estate private equity and hedge fund
products are closed off to something
like 97
of americans most people are not going
to buy a private island or trade large
alphabet options but there's a way for
everyday folks to invest in art you
might be wondering why anyone would
invest in art but when you realize that
contemporary art prices beat gold real
estate and the s p 500 returns by nearly
twofold from 1995 to 2020 now you
understand why and you can invest in
multi-million dollar art with
masterworks they're the investment
platform worth over one billion dollars
that lets people invest in art they've
securitized over 250 million dollars
worth of art realized a 32 percent
annualized return for their investors
from a banksy sale and signed up over
220 000 members many of them are fellow
ben shapiro listeners demand to join the
platform is really high luckily i've
partnered with masterworks to get vip
passes you can skip right to the front
of the line to secure your spot today
head on over to masterworks dot io slash
ben that is masterworks dot io slash ben
before deciding to invest carefully
review the important disclosures at
masterworks dot io
disclaimer okay so
yesterday protesters showed up at
netflix and it wasn't like a massive
crowd of protesters it was like you know
a few dozen people and they showed up
outside netflix and this was a national
news story now you should ask yourself
two questions one why are people
protesting outside of netflix and two
why should anyone care because protests
happen all over the united states for a
variety of reasons and yet they do not
receive international
let alone national media attention they
just don't receive any of that sort of
attention so the real question is why is
it that the media are obsessed with
covering like a few dozen people who are
pissed off at netflix as opposed to all
the other issues in the world and the
answer is because deep down in their
hearts members of the media are these
protesters and by covering this sort of
stuff they get to feel virtuous
according to the wall street journal a
group of protesters gathered outside one
of netflix's la offices wednesday to
express anger over streaming giant dave
chappelle's comedy special as some
employees released demands for
management and staged a walkout first of
all um your demands will not be met and
you can enjoy unemployment anytime you
see fit in the special the closer
chappelle made jokes and remarks
regarding gender many in the transgender
community including some netflix
staffers found offensive the company has
defended the special citing reasons
including the company's commitment to
artistic freedom
okay we have some video of the
protesters and um they uh they were not
acting well there's uh some counter
protesters uh one of them was carrying a
sign that said we like dave and this
prompted one of the the
very
sensitive
and and deeply
emotionally in touch protesters to
immediately tear down that sign and take
it apart
[Music]
we like dave unacceptable you don't like
dave no he starts tearing tearing parts
i know imagine had somebody been holding
a pro tran sign and somebody came along
and started tearing that up
national news story transphobia
he said wow taking down that sign like
like a boss like a boss what a hero
what a hero that human was
okay and uh and then
they they had scuffles and shouting at
the netflix protest i love these people
who also get up in your face like this
there's a guy he's literally just
standing there holding his sign and then
the lady who comes up at the end i
assume she's she's a lady i don't mean
to misgender anybody who comes up at the
end like stands right in front of him
like she's boxing me out from a rebound
first of all if this guy goes for
rebound over this person um that is not
a contest that says charles barkley
going up against mugsy bugs but in any
case
that was not all of the video from this
again this is not a major protest guys
this is like a few dozen people it got
massive front page national attention
hey here's some more of the video from
the protest
this guy has a sign i think the same guy
has assigned his jokes are funny
and now they're chanting trans lives
matter so it's it's hilarious
another guy's assigned says dave is
funny and they're chanting trans lives
matter so there's nothing quite as funny
as watching some members of the
intersectional coalition
adopt the rubric of other members of the
interac intersectional coalition
isn't that cultural appropriation i
thought it was black lives matter so now
trans are going trans lives matter
against a black man so that's really
really entertaining
according to the wall street journal
some netflix employees attended the
event but didn't speak supporters of the
comedian also showed up and tried to
disrupt the proceedings the event was
organized by ashley preston a trans
activist if your satire is punching down
you're being a bully ashley preston said
i'm tired of companies like netflix
making money off of trauma to my
community okay so let's just point out
one thing here it is not punching down
to call out a massive now mainstream
media movement to force americans to use
non-biological pronouns that is not
punching down that is a major issue of
public contention in today's day and age
and you know this because you literally
have institutions in american life who
are pushing this like from the top
levels of power i mean for goodness sake
you had the state department pushing
this yesterday the state department
celebrated international pronouns day
yesterday and they put out like an
actual tweet celebrating international
pronouns day quote today on
international pronouns day we share why
many people list pronouns on their email
and social media profiles read more here
on share america
and they have a little graphic of a
woman says she her and then a man says
he him and then a
woman that says they them and then a
woman that says he him says why do many
americans list pronouns on social media
profiles this is your state department
i'm so glad that we can push this via
the state department read once learn why
it matters what pronouns you use to
refer to people and how the united
states embracing embraces sharing
pronouns
but don't if you make fun of this then
that's punching down even though it's
coming from the state department by the
way very much looking forward to seeing
how the state department celebrates
international don't abandon 19 million
women to the predations of the taliban
day
that'll be that'll be really exciting
stuff from the state department where we
share pronouns because we care so much
about people who are gender
non-conforming but also are happy to
turn over 19 million women to the
taliban
solid priorities there over at the state
department so it is not punching down
okay when you when you make jokes about
about the question of whether trans
people are in fact members of the sex to
which they claim membership that is not
punching down by the way if you want to
talk about quote unquote punching down
dave chappelle makes two separate
anti-semitic jokes in the closer and no
one in the jewish community seems to
care because if you're a left-wing jew
you don't care because you agree with
him and if you're a white and if you're
a right-wing jew or if you're a
traditional jew in any way you're like
yeah he made a joke welcome to the real
world
the extent of the walkout wasn't clear
according to the wall street journal
many employees are working remotely in a
list of demands sent to netflix
management a group of transgender
employees called on the company to
create a new fund to develop trans and
non-binary talent recruit more trans
people into leadership roles and add a
disclaimer before transphobic titles
that specifically flag transphobic
language misogyny homophobia hate speech
etc as required
the employees wrote these changes and
others were necessary to quote avoid
future instances of platforming
transphobia and hate speech and to
account for the harm we have caused and
will continue to cause until the below
measures are put in place so in other
words pay us money and give us better
jobs and if you give me more money and
better job and then you slap like a
little warning then you can put on the
dave chappelle special to pay my salary
is what they're saying which is pretty
cynical
right they're not calling for netflix
never to put up a dave chappelle special
again they're saying that if you put up
a dave chappelle special you have to put
up a little disclaimer at the front so
we can pretend that we did our
due diligence and then you have to give
us a better job it's the same thing
disney does right disney does this
stupid routine or if you watch aladdin
they put up a little warning beforehand
saying this movie traffics and cultural
stereotypes now enjoy the film because
they're not going to take down aladdin
because everybody loves aladdin because
aladdin's a great movie so instead they
do this dumb routine where it's like yes
but if you watch this film you should
just remember that we're very sorry we
put it up but not sorry enough to
actually take it down because it's
important to be up so we can make money
off of you
a netflix spokeswoman declined to
comment on the specific demands now the
best part of this is that the netflix
co-chief executive ted serendo's
originally he had defended the chappelle
special originally he was like yeah you
know you guys are just gonna have to get
over it it makes a lot of money for us
and we believe that people should have
different perspectives and that's fine
now if you believed that from netflix
you're a sucker okay cause netflix
doesn't actually believe that wake me up
the next time netflix decides to do a
comedy special with somebody who's
actually right of center like any time
now but in any case serendos now has
walked that back a little bit he says
he's screwed up in his communications
with staff over the controversy he had
cited chappelle's popularity and said
the company didn't believe that
programming can spur real world harm he
said quote
i should have recognized the fact that a
group of our employees was really
hurting see this is where he would have
been better off just reading my credo
right facts don't care about your
feelings would have been a lot better
than i should have recognized that you
were hurting okay first of all if you
think that serendo's saying i see why
you're hurting would have led to them
being like okay he understands us
these people are so crazy if you are
this is how you bully a massive
billion-dollar corporation into doing
what you want you shout really loud and
then the person's like well maybe if i
just apologize a little bit they'll
leave me alone maybe if i just give the
alligator my little toe it won't get a
taste for me and then want to eat the
rest of me yeah good luck with that
sarandos
also in attendance was b pagle's miner
which sounds sort of like a bad concerto
who doesn't identify as male or female
and uses they as a pronoun so we know
literally nothing about this person
other than a very odd
surname b pagle's minor said they were
fired by netflix last week for
disclosing sensitive information outside
the company that ended up appearing in a
bloomberg media story
in an interview b pagle's minor
acknowledged sharing documents
internally but tonight providing the
information to any media outlets i
categorically deny leaking information
bpagglesminer said netflix was my family
i have no desire to hurt them
um so number one i do i always enjoy
reading stories where they have to play
around with the pronouns this way notice
how the media just falls right into it
right the media
is already on the side of the protesters
because they're doing everything the
protesters want instead of just saying
he she or or even they we're just going
to refer to this person by their actual
name so it sounds like ellen iverson
doing a press conference now right ellen
iverson doesn't like practice why did
allen iverson like to like pre why would
ellen iverson pass the ball ellen
iverson doing practice it's practice man
this is what we've got now from our news
stories bpaggles miners said that
bpaggles minor is the greatest b pagle's
minor since chopin's not turn in b minor
netflix said in a statement while we
would normally never talk about an
investigation like this these claims are
not supported by the facts this employee
admitted sharing confidential
information externally from their
netflix email on several occasions also
they were the only employee to access
the detailed sensitive data on four
titles that later appeared in the press
they claimed only to have shared this
information in an internal document and
said another employee must have leaked
it however that document was missing for
one title and so cannot have been the
source for the league
and then the employee wiped their device
okay so that's why the person was fired
now again why is this a national media
story the reason it's a national media
story is because the media are in league
with this the media are into this
okay here is some video of the netflix
walkout organizer bashing dave chappelle
here's what that sounded like
i want to make it very clear that this
isn't an instance of cancel culture
because i've invited dave chappelle to
have transformative dialogue with us on
multiple occasions
and he has made it clear that it is not
of interest to him so just to be clear
this isn't cancer culture but an
avoidance of accountability when we've
invited you to be a part of the repair
that it takes to be able to not only
heal culture but to
move all of us forward
it's not cancelled culture to try and
literally get somebody special removed
that's not cancelled culture anymore
it's accountability culture so it's it's
the reaction the media that i really
want to point out here protesters are
protesters everywhere they do stupid
things it is not a big shock the
reaction of the media is what's the
shock here it's like 11 people outside
netflix
there are more people who are upset with
cuties that are upset with dave
chappelle's special
like way more people and that was not a
national media story for more than about
30 seconds this chapel thing has lasted
for two weeks they're covering the
chappelle controversy longer than they
covered the pull out from afghanistan
not a joke
okay and and everybody's getting
involved if you're on the left you have
to virtue signal to demonstrate that
you're part of the intersectional
coalition because the cultural cram down
is in every area of american life by the
way if you think this stuff doesn't
matter politically or it doesn't move
votes you're wrong when people feel
inundated by stories like this their
immediate response is to flip the bird
to the cultural arbiters and then just
do precisely the opposite of what they
want
you want more trump this is how you get
more trump guys we'll talk about this in
just one second first
let's talk about the fact that you need
a great pillow at night it is just it is
just that simple and once you try my
pillow you're not going to want to try
anything else my pillow wants to give
back to our listeners you can get great
discounts on all my pillow products if
you go to mypillow.com right now and
click on that radio listener special get
deep discounts on my pillows mattress
toppers towels and so much more for
example my pillow is offering a buy one
get one free offer on giza sheets these
are top quality sheets you will love all
my pillow products come with a 60 day
money back guarantee and a 10 year
warranty head on over to mypillow.com
click on the radio listener specials for
the buy one get one free offer on the
giza sheets and use promo code daily
wire at checkout or call
1-800-651-1148 you'll also get deep
discounts on all my pillow products
including pillows slippers the my pillow
mattress topper and my pillow towel sets
that's mypillow.com enter code dailywire
or call 1-800-651-1148
tell them we sent you here at daily wire
that's
1-800-651-1148 those deals are not going
to last forever so call right now matt
pillow makes fantastic products you're
really going to enjoy them mypillow.com
enter daily wire for the special deals
right now okay so again the media
response is the part that's really
astonishing here so you have
an entire pbs newshour branding netflix
now a stigma brand they said netflix is
a stigma brand really so if you
subscribe to netflix a stigma is now put
upon you because seven people are mad at
netflix plus most of the mainstream
media
there are lots of people who are saying
that they don't wish to work with
netflix right now i've had producers um
and show runners tell me that they are
having people be fired and resigned and
the third thing is that netflix may
become a stigma brand that is to say it
may no longer be
a place where you're proud to say that
you're work that you work and if that's
the case they will lose employees to
their competitors who are dying to know
netflix's secrets and if those employees
employers allow those those new
employees to not only bring their
knowledge but also this desire for more
diverse content over time netflix could
be in real trouble
okay if you think that netflix is going
to be in real trouble because it's 11
trans employees walk across the street
to hulu
yeah sure
if you think there's gonna be a mass
walkout by the people in hollywood from
netflix which is currently paying them
exorbitant sums of cash to make movies
when the movie business is in a serious
fragmentary period you're out of your
mind but again the media got to push
this because it's not about what happens
to netflix it's about what happens to
you it's what happens to your business
because you're not netflix so next time
you get hit with the controversy know
that the media are going to put you on
the front page understand that all you
have to do is have one pissed off
employee with a picket sign outside your
store saying that you're transphobic and
it will be a national news story and
you're not netflix you're not a
multi-billion dollar company
okay and again the entire left
surrounding this thing is really
fascinating it really is because
think about this okay the afl-cio right
which is an industrially based
union coalition that's what the afl-cio
generally is
i would i would imagine the vast
majority of members of the afl-cio have
no dog in the dave chappelle versus the
trans folks at netflix fight not only
that i would imagine that the vast
majority of members of the f-l-cio
coalition
are not particularly up on using
pronouns in their bios and yet the head
of the afl-cio put out a notice quote
sending support to netflix employees
especially those in the trans resource
group walking out today for human rights
dignity and respect on the job again
remember none of these people were fired
they're all being paid by netflix
netflix is paying for their health care
netflix is paying all the payroll taxes
that like how did netflix disrespect
them by literally allowing a thing to be
said they didn't like
according to the afl-cio head it's time
for netflix to listen to its lgbtq plus
employees and live up to its standards
of radical transparency
what what radical like what's the
transparency what's what's the critique
i don't even understand the critique but
the fact that the afl-cio is in league
with this demonstrates that again the
entire way that the left operates in the
political sphere is that the common man
does not matter the leadership matters
you have a bunch of white
liberal elites college graduates who are
siding with the most radical elements of
various groups in order to cobble
together a coalition that they think
will be politically successful
if you just feed enough members of the
coalition something then they will all
stick by each other and create a certain
solidarity this all started on campuses
by the way
where you would have these bizarre
coalitions of like the lgbtq club and
the muslim club on campus
protesting israel and you'd be like whoa
what why is the lgbtq club protesting
israel along with the muslim club which
there's not a single muslim country on
planet earth that has any significant
level of tolerance toward gay people so
what's the story and the answer is if
you can form a coalition then the lgbtq
club knows the muslims are going to show
up for whatever they're protesting right
that sort of logic now applies
from campus to broader life so you got
the afl-cio an industrially based
coalition that is backing trans workers
against their employers and netflix why
because again if you go after employers
then maybe you'll get them to support
the afl cio next time you need them to
walk out
the fact that the media are so into this
is really
it's really demonstrative of the massive
disconnect between the elitists who try
to cram culture down on the rest of us
and the rest of us and it's ongoing and
it's consistent it's continuous by the
way we here at dailywire enjoy it keep
trying to do this because all you are
doing is driving more people out into
the cornfield and we are out here in the
corn field selling stuff they actually
want and we're going to be doing more of
that so if you want to create a market
share for us please continue with this
nonsense
like truly i hope that netflix caves to
the lgbtq plus radicals i hope that they
do i hope that they tell dave chappelle
they'll never do a special with him
again we're out here man if dave
chappelle wants you to do a special with
us we'll do it
if ricky gervais wants to do a special
with us we'll do it here at daily
weather like seriously keep driving
talent over to us it's really great
but there's a columnist at the
washington post this demonstrates again
where the the minds of the media are
when it comes to how you should think
culturally quote netflix employees at
the streaming giants campuses around the
world walked off the job wednesday in
protest of dave chapelle's latest
special the company's defense of the
comedian and its dismissal of concerns
that the content was dangerously
transphobic first of all this rubric
that it is actually dangerous to make a
joke about the trans cause which again
is anti-biology and anti-reality
is absurd it's absurd
and there's a piece of psychology today
about this quote there's little evidence
that offensive media causes real world
harm
correct it's just something you claim
because if you can claim that something
is dangerous then you can try to shut it
down
right if you normally say i just don't
like what you're saying so i want you to
shut up and we all understand that
you're a censorious fascist but if you
say it harms me it's dangerous for me if
you say this then we're like oh well if
it's dangerous then maybe we should shut
it down i mean if if speech is violence
then maybe we need to silence the speech
according to this columnist in
psychology today is there evidence to
suggest a comedy special such as
chappelle's could increase violence
rates the good news is there's not clear
evidence linking entertainment media to
violence in real life
even some professional guilds like the
american psychological association are
sometimes caught on a limb
uh caught out on a limb of promoting
moral panic with bad signs this sort of
stuff happens all the time again because
it's politically driven not
scientifically driven but this is the
washington post columnist helena andrews
dyer saying quote a crowd of dozens
gathered outside the streamer's west
hollywood offices
to announce both chappelle and the
company's chief executive ted sarandos
dozens you hear dozens
i mean
honestly like dozens a crowd of the
assembled dozens
we're we're maddened they're paying for
the blood of ted sarandos the assembled
dozens very intimidating stuff right
there some supporters of chappelle
attended the rally clashing with
protesters as they urged netflix not to
limit speech and held up signs with
messages such as jokes are funny
we're here today not because we can't
take a joke said ashley murray preston
media personality and the walkouts
organizer we're here today because the
jokes are taking lives the jokes
how
hell you just walking down the street
and suddenly a joke pounces from a
shadowed doorway and stabs you directly
in the eye with the punchline
and down you go bleeding from your eye
socket and as you fade into
unconsciousness you think to yourself
man should have gotten policy genius
like i don't understand how does the
the jokes are taking lives the jokes are
taking lives these idiots
the issue exploded after the october
fifth release of the comedian special in
which he compares being trans to wearing
blackface makes jokes about transgender
people's genitalia and declares he's
team turf which stands for
trans-exclusionary radical feminist
because he believes that gender is a
fact
he compares the struggles of the black
community directly with the lgbtq
community he said i can't help but feel
like if slaves had baby oil and booty
shorts we might have been free a hundred
years sooner
in their list of demands to serendos the
netflix employee resource group trans
little star which consists of trans and
non-binary employees wrote in a news
release they want the company to add
disclaimers make investment in trans
creators recruit trans people to work in
netflix leadership roles
but again the fact that this is driven
such media attention demonstrates that
it is not about where people think the
cultural action culture actually is it's
what they think the culture should be
and you should shut up and you should
take it
and this is the nature of how culture
changes like the media now represent a
hardcore
minority of radicals who are going to
change the culture whether you like it
or not and they're going to excise you
from the culture whether you like it or
not we have some more examples of this
in just a moment because it is again it
seems bizarre up until the point when it
actually comes for you and your kids in
school and your business we'll get some
more of it a second first let's talk
about a simple fact if something is off
in the bedroom very often the tendency
for people is to sort of wait on it okay
well it'll probably go away very often
it's not going to go away you should
just go get the medical problem solved
go to getroman.com ben right now
with roman you get a free online
evaluation and ongoing care for edie all
from the comfort and privacy of your
home a us licensed healthcare
professional will work with you to find
the best at treatment plan if medication
is appropriate it ships you free with
two day shipping the whole process is
straightforward and discreet getting
started is simple just go to
getroman.com
complete an online visit today take care
of your ed without leaving your home
complete an online visit today connect
with a healthcare professional and get
it taken care of go to getroman.com
right now you'll get 15 off your very
first month of ed treatment it's time to
take care of the ed don't wait around on
it again medical problems people tend to
ignore them hoping that eventually they
will solve themselves sometimes it
happens but if it's not happening for
you don't wait any longer because it can
really affect your life go to
getroman.com ben right now get started
today you say 15 bucks on your first
order of ed treatment that is
g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n-com
ben right now okay so it is it is not
just with regard to netflix that the
cultural arbiters are determining what
the rest of us are supposed to think and
if you question it then you are labeled
intolerant if you question it then you
are labeled outside the bounds of moral
discourse
i mean corporations will spend literally
hundreds of millions of dollars in order
to convince you that something is
popular that is not popular right now
they're trying to convince you that the
trans movement the trans rights movement
is extraordinarily popular in the united
states it is not they're trying to
convince you that the movement to
drug your kids at the age of 15
with with hormones and then prepare them
for surgery is popular in america it is
not
they're trying to convince you that
people making jokes is unacceptable
most americans don't believe that
and
like the stubbornness with which these
narratives are pursued is truly telling
my favorite example is uh is the wnba so
the wnb is not a thing i'm sorry it's
never going to be a thing you can't make
fetch happen it's just never going to be
a thing
in the wnba i'm not saying that women
shouldn't play basketball women can play
basketball but if you're going to
pretend there's a massive market for
women playing basketball and people
watching them you're out of your mind
and the reason you're out of your mind
is because a good high school boys
basketball team could beat a wnba team
i couldn't i suck at basketball but a
good high school boys basketball team
could beat a wnba team
and literally it is a story in the wnba
when somebody dunks it is not even a
story when a high school player dunks in
the boys side
he now again women can play basketball
they're more skilled than i all of that
is fine and dandy but there is this
mainline effort in the media to promote
the notion that the wnba is the thing
when it is clearly not a thing espn
tries to cover the wnba's though it is
equivalent in interest level to any
other major sport
when the wnba's fan
in like singular
is just that a fan
right the the grand total number of
people who care about the wnba are the
executives at the nba who want to
pretend that they care about gender
parity while paying wnba players 40 000
a year and nba players 40 million
dollars a year
and the
immediate families of the people in the
wnba and some very driven feminists who
are apparently willing to sacrifice an
evening of time to watch
somebody play the the
four corners offense essentially okay so
this was made humiliatingly clear
yesterday
[Music]
so the chicago sky apparently they're a
team in a league that exists
yeah didn't really know or care really
because who who does so they had a
championship celebration so the
championship celebration started off at
uh the park
uh is it millennium park i guess in
chicago and some people showed up no
crowd estimates and then they had a
parade
and people were like well you know just
because nobody showed up for the parade
doesn't mean people didn't show up at
the park yes but normally when you have
like a the golden state warriors win an
nba championship people show up for the
parade too the video of the parade is a
deeply humiliating to the wnba as well
it should be and remember the nba
subsidizes the wnba to the tune of like
tens of millions of dollars every year
um
you if you can't see this there are
buses of people going down the street
open air buses there are four buses
first of all i don't know how big this
team is
there are four buses
no one on the street
no one i mean i like the assembled
score of people cheered ecstatically as
the buses passed
the assembled small group of people who
could fit in a telephone booth
cheered wildly ah the excitement can you
feel the excitement at the wnba here can
you feel it
wow palpable palpable excitement i mean
people haven't been this excited since
the release of ishtar
the bicyclist and the people honest to
god the people on the top of the bus
wildly outnumber the number of people
who are supposedly cheering them
it's it's really like it's an amazing
site because they've spent tens of
millions of dollars over the years to
try and make the wnba happen it's not
happening again that is not a rip on the
players because the players have a
certain level of talent and a thing that
is not marketable
i mean sorry
and yet there's an attempt by the
culture to continue to force it down and
it just won't end and watch because i'm
saying this people get very angry at me
because i'm merely pointing out that
there is no crowd for the wnba and no
one cares about the wnba it'll be like
uh you're a sexist that's why you're
even pointing this out
no i'm just pointing out that there are
cultural arbiters who try to tell you
that things are popular that are not
popular and that things are unpopular
when they are popular right netflix is
in real trouble because 12 people walked
out of the netflix headquarters netflix
is in serious trouble and you should
know that next time you think about
telling a joke about transness
but also the wnba is wildly popular so
popular and man people can be so pissed
at you if you make fun of the fact that
no one showed up for by the way it's
been a long running joke that no one
watches wnba games i mean nor mcdonald
was making jokes about this like 20
years ago family guy has an episode
where they show a wnba game and then it
cuts to
the fan
that's one guy in an empty stadium
and i'm sorry that's that's right and
it's hilarious the thing about leftist
views of culture is that they run up
against reality but it is also true that
sometimes not always but sometimes if
you just keep pushing and you push hard
enough and you just keep pushing
eventually you shift the entire culture
in your direction which is why you get
the stubbornness and normally if you're
the nba and you run up against the hard
reality then nobody wants to watch the
wnba just shut it down you're like okay
we could use that money better elsewhere
but instead you insist on promoting it
because maybe just maybe you will change
the landscape
all right
keep trying it keep trying it
and again the cram down from it's a very
small group of people who are trying to
define the cultural taste
it's not working in the case of the wnba
because i mean there's just no way i'm
sorry like there are certain things that
that rational human beings just won't do
rational human beings don't run into
traffic rational human beings don't jump
off of 100 story buildings and rational
people don't watch wnba games almost
forced to do so
but the thing is that this sort of you
know cultural
control does have real world
consequences on a smaller scale and with
regard to particular issues so for
example on college campuses this
continues to be a major problem right it
is this view by the way of things like
the wnba that leads to the title mind
stupidity wherein
sports
is supposed to be equivalent in colleges
between men and women
like that that's that's very silly right
women's softball is not the same as as
men's baseball for example but in any
case
a good example of sort of how the
cultural arbiters decide things
comes courtesy of mit according to the
new york times
michael powell reporting the
massachusetts institute of technology
invited the geophysicist dorian abbott
to give a prestigious public lecture
this autumn he seemed a natural choice a
scientific star who studies climate
change and whether planets in distant
solar systems might harbor atmospheres
conducive to life then a swell of angry
resistance arose some faculty members
and grad students argued that dr abbott
a professor at the university of chicago
had created harm
harm by speaking out against the aspects
of affirmative action and diversity
programs right so people are making the
same claim about this
geophysicist dorian abbott that they're
making about dave chappelle he's
creating harm what was the harm
in videos and opinion pieces dr abbott
has asserted that such programs treat
quote people as members of a group
rather than individuals repeating the
mistake that made possible the
atrocities of the 20th century he said
he favored a diverse pool of applicants
selected on merit
so that
inarguable fact which is that when you
use affirmative action you are treating
people based on group characteristic
rather than individual merit which is
inarguable it is literally the purpose
of affirmative action the purpose of
affirmative action is that black people
historically were discriminated against
therefore we must affirmatively
discriminate in favor of black people in
applications in order to rectify the
breach
he points this out and says that this
cuts directly against the notion of
individual merit and judges people on
the basis of group which has a very ugly
history in the 20th century
and this caused the lecture to be
withdrawn
he said that his planned lecture at mit
would have made no mention of his views
on affirmative action but his opponents
in the sciences argued he represented a
quote infuriating inappropriate and
oppressive choice
on september 30th mit reversed course
the head of its earth atmospheric and
planetary sciences department called off
dr abbott's lecture to be delivered to
professors grad students and the public
including some top black and latino high
school students
robert van der hilst the head of the
department at mit said quote besides
freedom of speech we have the freedom to
pick the speaker who best fits our needs
words matter and have consequences
ever more fraught arguments over speech
and academic freedom on american
campuses have moved as a as a flood tide
into the sciences biology physics math
all have seen fierce debates over
courses hiring an objectivity and some
on the academic left have moved to
silence those who disagree on certain
questions
a few fields have purged scientific
terms and names seen by some as
offensive there is a rising call for
citational justice arguing that
professors and grad students should seek
to cite more black latino asian and
native american scholars and in some
cases refuse to acknowledge in footnotes
the research of those who hold
distasteful views
that's unbelievable so you actually have
major universities now deciding whether
or not you're allowed to cite a
scientifically useful or innovative
paper based on the race of the person
who wrote that i mean this is soviet
science
there's life centralism the only type of
science that is approved is the science
approved by the state
it's frankly it sounds like the the nazi
treatment of quote unquote jewish
science right if it's if it comes from
the jews it can't be good science so if
it comes from this white guy it can't be
a good innovative piece of scientific
literature that's insane
i'm not saying it's a prelude to a
holocaust i'm saying that that is a that
is a piece of anti-science
propagandistic trash and it is
undeserving of our of any level of
respect
they're literally saying that they want
to refuse to acknowledge in footnotes
the research of people who hold
distasteful views normally when you
refuse to acknowledge in a footnote
where you're getting a piece that's
called plagiarism joe biden is quite
familiar with it
but apparently they now want you to not
cite people if those people hold outside
views that you don't like
i hate to break it to these people but
literally every scientist up until the
last five minutes disagreed with them on
politics
i promise you there are things i'm sure
that einstein said that you would
disagree with so i guess you can never
cite einstein again
the decision by mit viewed as a high
citadel of science in the united states
took back some prominent scientists
debate and argumentation impassioned
even ferocious is the mother's milk of
science they said jerry coyne emeritus
professor of evolutionary biology at the
university of chicago said i thought
scientists would not get on board with
it with the denial of free speech
movement i was absolutely wrong 100
percent
dr abbott spoke of his shock when told
his speech was canceled i didn't know
what to say we're not going to do the
best science that we can if we are
constrained ideologically
no sooner had mit canceled his speech
than robert george director of
princeton's james madison program in
american ideals and institutions invited
him to give the speech there on thursday
the same day as as the cancelled lecture
dr george says mit has behaved
disgracefully in capitulating to a
politically motivated campaign this is
part of a larger trend of the
politicization of science
and then the story took another turn
this week because david romps a
professor of climate physics at the
university of california berkeley
announced he would be resigning as
director of the berkeley atmospheric
sciences center he said he had tried to
persuade his fellow scientists and
professors to invite abbott
in my view he said there are some
institutional principles we have to hold
sacred okay but apparently they uh they
did not want him to
they agreed that this scientist should
not be able to speak
the controversy surrounding dr abbott's
cancer talk speaks as well to attention
manifest in progressive circles between
social justice and free speech some
faculty members have come to see
identity and racial inequities as more
urgent than questions of muzzled speech
phoebe cohen is a geosciences professor
and department chair at williams college
one of many who express anger
on twitter at mit's original decision to
invite dr abbott to speak
cohen agreed dr abbott's views reflect a
broad current in american society
ideally she said a university should not
invite speakers who do not share its
values on diversity and affirmative
action nor was she enamored of mit's
offer to let him speak at a later date
to the mit professors
to me the professional consequences are
extremely minimal she said
what she was asked of the effect on
academic debate should the academy serve
as a bastion of unfettered speech
here is her answer and this is
everything quote this idea of
intellectual debate and rigor as the
pinnacle of intellectualism comes from a
world in which white men dominated
that is
insane
i'm sorry that's insane it's also racist
if the idea of intellectual debate and
rigor is restricted to white people or
as a white people invention that is the
most you know who agrees with that david
duke that is the most racist thing i
have read today for sure
that is insane
intellectual rigor and debate as a
pinnacle of intellectualism if it had
been up to apparently the people of
color around the world these things
would be a very low priority
you mean science
and people debating idea wow what a
statement but again these are these are
the people who hold power in a wide
variety of institutions
and eventually that will have an impact
on how we live not just at the
universities not just with regard to
companies like netflix but the kind of
content you can consume
the kind of things you're allowed to say
out loud you wonder why people are
living in political fear right now
that's why people are living in
political fear right now we all know it
and this stuff has real world
consequences it's going to have
political consequences as well the left
is constantly saying things like why do
you even care about this there's this
gaslighting effect why do you care about
this why are you paying attention to the
cultural cram-downs after all you don't
have to pay attention until you make me
pay attention you will be made my friend
eric erickson suggested you will be made
to care
hands-off is not a policy that redounds
to your own benefit at this point
okay in just a second we'll get to the
biden administration announcing the
long-awaited ability to get a vaccine if
you are five years old when i say
long-awaited i mean not all that many
people were deeply concerned about it if
they had checked any of the stats we'll
get to that in just one moment first
let's talk about another podcast you
should give a listen to the jordan
harbinger show it's a podcast you should
try i know every day somebody tells you
you have to listen to some podcast or
other and most of you just kind of nod
and then you forget about it but you
should check out jordan's show apple
named it one of its best of 2018 it is
aimed at making you a better informed
more critical thinker so you can get a
sense of how the world actually works
and come to your own conclusions about
what's happening even inside your own
brain each episode is a conversation
with a different fascinating guest when
i say there's something for everyone
here i really mean it in one episode
jordan talks to a hostage negotiator
from the fbi who offers techniques on
how to get people to like and trust you
which sounds useful and somewhat
disturbing at the same time you should
check out jordan's conversations with
people like scott adams maybe jack
shafer even though i don't always agree
with jordan his interviews are always
fascinating i always learn something we
here at dailywear enjoy the show you
will too there's a lot here check out
jordanharbinger.comstart for some
episode recommendations or search for
the jordan harbinger show that's h-a-r-b
is in boy i-n is a nancy g-e-r on apple
podcast spotify or wherever you listen
to podcasts that's jordanharbinger.com
start and see which episodes appeal to
you all right we're going to get into
the biden administration now pushing
coveted shots on kids which is the next
step first
you deserve nothing less than the facts
with your morning coffee we are here to
supply them on our newest podcast
morning wire not only has it been
topping the apple and spotify charts
since its release it is the only daily
podcast that values your time and the
truth and while we are working overtime
to bring you the news you need to know
we need your help to keep those facts
trending toward number one so subscribe
and start listening right now to morning
wire on apple spotify or wherever you
listen to podcasts leave a five star
review if you like what you hear you are
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
[Music]
alrighty meanwhile the biden
administration is preparing for covet
shots for five to eleven-year-olds the
white house covet coordinator jeff sense
he says we now have enough shots for all
of the kitties here he was yesterday
we have secured vaccine supply to
vaccinate every child ages 5 through 11.
and as soon as the vaccine is authorized
by the fda we will begin shipping
millions of dosha doses nationwide
states tribes and territories are
working to ensure that doses continue to
be distributed efficiently
and equitably across their jurisdictions
and importantly we worked with pfizer to
modify the packaging of the pediatric
doses to make it easier for
pediatricians
family doctors and other providers to
provide vaccines to children
okay so i have a question were you
concerned about your five to 11 year old
because if so i'm wondering exactly how
concerned you were it's one thing to say
you know on the off chance that maybe my
kid is going to really suffer from covet
i'll get the vaccine i've looked at the
stats and i think that maybe the vaccine
is going to be safer for my kid than the
alternative of actually getting covet
but if either of these things is like
deeply worrying you on a serious level
you should just understand that
according marty mccary of johns hopkins
10 to 20 kids total across the entire
pandemic have died i'm talking now
between 5 and 11. i'm talking between 0
and 18 have died without serious
pre-existing conditions in the united
states over the entire course of the
pandemic out of 700 000 people
10 to 20. okay so you're saying to
yourself should i get the vaccine for my
kid i don't know the answer to that i
get my kids the flu shot because flu is
more dangerous to my kids than covet is
i'm concerned about giving my seven and
five-year-old the coveted shot because
frankly there's no longitudinal data the
entire sample size of four physical
study was 2300 kids we know that
myocarditis was appearing for the second
shot for teenagers about one in nine
thousand occasions so a sample size of
2300 isn't even large enough to detect
how often myocarditis is gonna is going
to crop up in kids also we don't really
know how often myocarditis is happening
in kids from covet itself so you really
have no comparative stats at this point
and no longitudinal data so there are
serious questions to be asked about
getting the covered vaccine again your
kid getting coveted should not be at the
top of your risk chart for your kids
kids get sick all the time kids put
themselves in danger all the time on the
list of things that can kill your kid
covet is very very low ranking like
extremely low ranking so what you might
have said to yourself is okay well
i understand all of that
and i'm kind of indifferent as to
whether my kid gets a copy vaccine but
you know i'm okay with getting a covered
vaccine i'm not like super anti-it fair
enough that's fine the real reason i
want to get my kid vaccinated is because
then my kids will be able to go to
school without masks because then we'll
be done right i mean they'll be
vaccinated all the kids will be
vaccinated we'll have slowed the spread
my kid will be immune and everything
will be hunky-dory wrong dr rochelle
wolensky of the cdc announced yesterday
that even after your kids are vaccinated
you're five-year-olds who should not be
massed in schools anyway okay let's face
it there is no data none that masking
five-year-olds has been effective in
lowering the hospitalization and death
rate
there is zero evidence that kids need to
be masked in schools
there are many countries that do not
mask small children in schools including
great britain and all of the all of the
nordic countries
the this belief this this religious
belief that slapping a cloth mask on a
five-year-old somehow is going to
protect them from the disease is
unsupportable by any of the available
data right now it's just not supportable
delta has a very high viral load kids do
not know how to wear masks kids are
constantly picking at their masks
even medical professionals don't wear
ppe properly you think that your
five-year-old's wearing your ppe
properly if you've ever seen the inside
of your kid's mask at the end of the day
it is all snot and boogers and it's just
yeah sure i'm sure it's working great
okay so
right now before the vaccines there's no
reason that you should be masking
five-year-olds and yes it does damage to
five-year-olds psychologically when they
see nothing but masks all day it is
irritating to kids
it annoys them they get headaches it
hurts their ears
they seeing faces is very critical for i
mean it's amazing how we just threw out
the actual science on this the
neuroscience on this is absolutely clear
seeing faces for children is really
really important there are all sorts of
orphanage studies from places like
romania and china demonstrating that
when kids in developmental stages do not
see faces it actually damages them but
we've pretended for a year and a half
like that's not the case because the
american psychological association and
the american academy of pediatrics has
decided to just mirror whatever the
leftist priority of the day is here's
rashel wallensky announcing that even if
you get your kid the jab your kids still
can't take off the mask which i'm sorry
this is crazy this is a recipe for
masking for the rest of time there is no
falsifiability to this
and there are people
all over the united states on health
boards for schools who have taken the
position that literally there is no
metric by which the masks will ever be
removed they cannot tell you at what
point your risk is low enough for the
mass to be removed from your kid here's
richarlinsky doing this routine
yesterday
we will be working to scale up pediatric
vaccination that's that will take some
time and as i just noted as we head into
these winter months we know we cannot be
complacent we also know that um previous
data that that schools that have had
masks in place were three and a half
times less likely to have school
outbreaks requiring school closure so
right now we are going to continue to
recommend masks in all schools for all
um people in those schools
there's no end of this road okay i know
there are a lot of people out there even
on the center right who are saying well
you know if i get my kid jabbed then
maybe they'll leave us alone they're
never going to leave you alone they're
not leaving you alone is the point some
of them are saying this openly jacob
stern who's a columnist for the atlantic
is now saying you know what happened
last year it's really fascinating there
are basically no flu cases in the united
states last year now that's because
there wasn't a virulent flu strain that
was on the on the rise also there's been
some suspicion that the testing for
covet was also catching up flu in the
test okay but let's assume that it was
really just the masking all right let's
assume that the masking cut down on
covert but it also cut down on the flue
because the flue is not quite as
transmissible as covid
now they're saying jacob stern is saying
maybe we should just mask forever kids
get the flu flu's deadly maybe we should
just continue asking people forever they
don't want to get back to normal that's
the entire point the control is the
point
and when they talk about vaccinating
kids i have no trust by the way they're
not going to try and make this mandatory
i got in a bit of a tiff yesterday with
uh some yaya rosenberg online because he
was angry at me for pointing out that
very few kids had died from covid
and thus the
the notion that you should be panicked
about making sure your kid gets a shot
in the same way that you wore about your
75 year old father mother or grandparent
getting the shot was was very silly like
i wanted to make sure that my
grandparents got the shot my
grandmother's got the shot like asap i
want to make sure my parents got the
shot asap didn't care about my kids
getting the shot because i can actually
read a risk chart
okay but that was my he was saying well
yeah but you know you shouldn't
discourage people from getting the
vaccine i'm not it's your choice but i
don't think that it's gonna remain your
choice very long lausd has already said
all kids above the age of 12 need to get
vaccinated you think they're gonna
restrict it to that
you think they're gonna stop there
they're immediately gonna move to
five-year-olds they're gonna be saying
that your five-year-old must get
vaccinated or cannot go to school
that is the direction it is all about
the control why and now they're new
excuses well you know your five-year-old
could infect grandma
yeah well guess what my five-year-old
sick all the time because he's five
and if grandma's really that
immunocompromised then she should be
socially distancing from my kids
regardless because kids are little
disease bags that is what they are they
carry around stuff all the time they're
constantly sick and wiping their nose
because they're developing immunity
that's what you do as a child
it is patently crazy the way that this
administration is approaching these
issues and to pretend that now that the
kids are vaccinated they're going to let
you go back to normal no they won't they
will not they're fully invested in the
idea that they they've set themselves a
bar they can never surpass the bar is
zero coveted it's never going to happen
and so long as it's never going to
happen they're continuing maintaining
this stuff because the great danger to
them
is that it is proved once and for all
that government cannot fix all of your
problems not even the biggest problems
like disease all right we'll be back
here later today with an additional hour
of content coming up soon as the matt
wall show it airs at 1 30 pm eastern be
sure to check it out over at
dailywire.com i'm ben shapiro this is
the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavel
wydowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciavitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica kranz the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show